the Joe Rogan experience but it's it's
just that that whole idea that you've
got to this I mean my life is so heavily
affected by drugs even though I had this
whole you know I'm not gonna do any
drugs why did you have that decision you
know I don't know I don't know that's
always and I've talked about this on my
podcast forever you know I tidy now was
it how old you know I'm 64 years old and
you have no experience with drugs other
than medication surgery maybe yes and I
have I've had deep enough injuries that
I have experienced keep getting surgery
because you love drugs well you know
Trey Parker said that my big flaw was
never having been high so he fix that
sorry I don't
so he did fix that I went in for dental
surgery
serious dental surgery and they [ __ ]
up and the the dentist told the nurse
what he had given me in terms of
painkillers and she took that as what
she was supposed to give me so instantly
doubled the dose and I was so [ __ ]
high and out of my mind you know can die
that way yeah and I told my wife through
my haze of not knowing who I was
call Trey Parker drag came to Vegas and
said I want to sit with Ben hi how long
did it take you to get to you he was
planning on being there like it came
like a day early oh so he got he got
there like I was still high and Trey
said I didn't remember anything and Trey
said the next day I was right you should
be high well there's different kinds of
high it's just like there's different
kinds of music and you know I was very I
was very I was very close to Lou Reed
mm-hmm and I was a very good friend of
mine and Lou said speaking on behalf of
the people of Earth which I often do we
don't want to see
don't do it so Lou says no traces yes
what does Jo say well Jo this is
interesting because I wanted to talk to
you about this because we had a
conversation a long time ago about this
and you said that I don't remember this
very clearly I may paraphrase us but you
said I think we've learned all there is
to know and I don't need to do it oh yes
I said that and I was wrong yeah yeah
just well I think you should experience
psychedelics because I think
psychedelics are a totally different
thing they don't take you we know Sam
Harris sure and Sam Harris is the one
who got me meditating ha which took him
years of arguing with me and now it's
been 3 or 4 years that I have not missed
a day not mister day you you have a
problem here's morning problems you're
very intelligent you're also very large
and you're very articulate and people
like to hear you talk so you just can
talk and you can take over you could
over run things and you can make an
argument that people just go alright and
they step back and that's good if you're
trying to win an argument but sometimes
it's bad to take in ideas and I remember
when I have that conference exactly
right thank you when I had that
conversation with you I remember saying
I'm gonna revisit this someday and one
day I want to get pen [ __ ] up on
mushrooms that's what I remember
thinking like it might be a good thing
for well the best thing for you would be
something that doesn't take very long
just so you can explai is the best one
because it takes like 15 minutes and
it's over and then your body brings it
back to baseline almost immediately so
you literally travel to another
dimension and then you're back and you
don't have to worry about any overdosing
because it's an endogenous chemical your
body knows exactly what to do it it's
one of the quickest chemicals that your
body could break down and bring back to
baseline in in my defense from the very
beginning of my not doing drugs which is
an odd odd kind of kind of baseline
there I always left the door open for
for psychedelics in the heart when I
what I disliked the most was wine with
dinner really I disliked the most social
kind of lubrication wine with dinners
amazing doing this in past tense you
know
that's that's where I that's right
that's where I always was and I always
left open the possibility of some of the
more intense stuff wine with dinner is a
delicious drug it's one of the rare
delicious drugs like I like whiskey but
let's be honest it tastes like [ __ ] it's
weird you're drinking the stuff that's
whoa like it's got kind of a good flavor
but it's like it's harsh you can't drink
it like it can't [ __ ] with kool-aid
kool-aid tastes way better than it's
cheap he doesn't mix it up it tastes
delicious it's way better tasting but
you know wine has a delicious taste that
you can enjoy here's my problem one of
my many problems will detail more than
one okay but I have no skill at
moderation I'm 64 years old and I've
never been able to do anything with
moderation mmm
so I think if you told me we're gonna do
acid for the rest of our lives every
single day you could make that argument
the idea for me that's hard like I said
but I said I was meditated I haven't
missed a day
maybe you should microdose yeah baby
yeah would you give you a little right
now just a little spray you do micro
dosing space do it now and I want to
think about it a little bit before it
well that would be pretty boss you get
the box right there so um how often do
you always gonna answer that question I
have a zillion answers to why I've never
done drugs and none of them are of
course true because we don't have access
to right that's stuff that we really do
but my parents and my whole family in
back generations teetotalers so there
was never alcohol in the house never I
never saw my parents take a drink when
it was on TV it was a totally different
thing it just didn't happen I didn't end
it they never preached about it they
never said don't drink they never said
don't do drugs it just never was in the
house and that statistically has a huge
effect on people and then the first
people I fell madly in love with you
know Lenny Bruce Jimi Hendrix had been
my mind killed by drugs mmm and I kind
of said who people would that have this
kind of personality when they get into
drugs they sometimes have trouble and I
think that maybe being 19 years old and
trying to get into show business that
maybe being the sober one allowed the
Dumber guy to do a little better you
know is everybody else kind of get out
of my way has ever [ __ ] up some of the
time I could get other stuff done and
then that starts reinforcing they may no
longer be valid